hello everyone welcome to another tango
technique class at home
i hope you are all doing fine uh today
will be
a bit back to basics because we will
work on pivots
yeah and the class will be equally
useful for men
and for women because the exercises we
will do
cover a very generic repertoire that is
useful for both
yeah now before we start one comment
about practicing pivots usually when
people practice pivots for download
they focus on how much can they turn
so they start for example with 90 degree
spheres
which is what i use in the class it's
the easiest
and then they continue with 180 degrees
keywords and then
270 degrees and 360 and sometimes even
more
and that's fine if you want to do that
that's fine but if that's the only thing
you do
then in my opinion that's not the most
useful work
yeah you are starting the building from
the roof
not from the bases why because
if you think about a normal dance that
you do
with your partner yeah most of the
pivots that you need
when you dance are the smallest ones are
the 90 degree skills that's the most
useful pivot
is the pivot that you're using most of
the time
you use 180 degrees pivots only in
figures where you are changing your
direction completely from one
from one side to another for example in
closed torches
and the bigger pivots you only use them
in very specific figures where you have
big rotations for example in planers
or in calicitas where you have a long
sustained rotation and in those figures
your partner
is a very important part of your pivot
so um if you
want to improve your all your downs your
your generic downs quickly i would
rather focus
on small pivots and make sure that your
technique in those small pivots is
correct
for example that your balance is right
during the whole people that you don't
fall that you don't
need the free food that your
dissociation is correct yeah that you
can separate your torsion your hip
correctly in the pivot
yeah because if you focus on those
things
on those technical aspects in small
pivots
your whole dance will improve okay so
today we will start with our warm up
then we will do a preparation exercise
about balance and dissociation
which is important for pivots and then
we will do
five exercises in which
we will put our free leg in different
positions meanwhile we do the pivot
sometimes we will put it behind
or to the side front in zero position
cross
front back yeah because each one of
these
positions for the free leg during a
pivot
are very useful for specific figures
and on each exercise i will show you for
which figure that specific exercise is
good for
okay so let's go for the warm up
okay warm up so put your feet together
first
and just take a few seconds to breathe
relax find your center and
let the weight of your body come down
through your legs
through your feet to the floor okay and
we start with shoulder rotation
so remember the important things about
this exercise
make a big circle yeah and
don't use the elbow when you rotate the
shoulder
yeah don't do this keep the arms relaxed
and then go straight yeah and we do
eight times
one two
three four
five six
seven eight now we do circles with the
arms
so remember as well keep the elbows
straight all the time yeah don't bend
the elbows especially when the arms are
up
keep them straight yeah you go from down
to front
then up and then you open to the sides
making sure that the hands are a little
bit behind the back so that you stretch
the
chest okay and we do it eight times
one two
three four
five six
seven and eight
yeah now we stretch the side of our
torso
so we lift one arm and then we slide
down
our leg with the other hand until we can
touch
the knee yeah we hold this stretch for
three seconds
and then we pull ourselves back vertical
and we drop the arm and we repeat with
the other arm okay
so we will do it four times to each side
now let's do it together
one go down
hold it and
up one
go down hold it
and other two
go down on the stretch
and up and two
go down hold the stretch
and up three
down hold it
and up and the last one we decide four
go down hold the stretch
[Music]
and up and four
go down hold the stretch
and up okay now we open the legs
a little bit wider than our shoulders
we bend the knees slightly and we make a
circle with the arms in front of us and
we will rotate the torso left and right
but make sure that when you rotate
the hips and your head are always
looking forward yeah don't move the hips
like this this is one
yeah it's bad for your knees and also
make sure that
the arms and the back are rotating
together
yeah don't move only the arms like this
because then your middle is not working
and the exercise is actually for torsion
okay
and we do it uh twice eight times
yeah so let's do it together and
one two three
four five
six seven eight
and eight more one two
three four
five six
seven and eight okay
now stretch the knees yeah we grab our
hips
and we go down yeah we will stretch the
back of our legs
and the lower back which is very useful
for tumble
yeah so go down until your back is
parallel with the floor like this and
then continue
going down yeah let your head hunt
and then bounce three times one two
three
and then go up again slowly yeah
don't go up too fast because you might
get busy okay
so let's do it eight times yeah go
forward
back parallel with the floor and then
bounce
bounce bounce and go up
two down parallel on the floor
bounce pass palms and go up
three go down
bounce bounce bounce go up
and four go down
bounce balls palms and go
up five go down
parallel to the floor bounce
bounce bounce and up slowly
six down keep the knees straight
bounce bounce bounce and up
seven go down bounce
bounce bounce and up and the last one
eight down bounce
pass and
up okay now we will do circles with the
hip
so we keep the hands on the hips and we
go back like this
and then we move the hip to the side
yeah make sure that your knees are
straight and heels on the floor yeah
and keep the head always in this
position yeah
then we move the hip forward yeah
then to the other side and then back
so we trace a circle yeah so we will do
eight times in one direction
and then eight times in the other
direction so let's do it together
one two
three four
five six
seven and eight now change direction
one two
three four
five six
seven eight
okay now we close our feet again
make sure that your feet are completely
closed touching each other
and we will work on the muscles of our
lower leg
yeah which are very important for
balance and for
strength okay so we bend the knees
and we bounce three times very relaxed
one two three and then we stretch the
knees
and then we go up on the toes and we
hold
this position for three seconds and then
we go down yeah
and we do it eight times so let's do it
together
one bounce bounce bounce
and up hold it
and down two bounce pass balance
go up hold it
and down three bounce pass bounce
and down four bounce bounce bounce
go up hold it
and down five bounce bounce bounce
down six bounce bounce bounce
go up hold it
and down seven bounce bounce bounce
and down eight bounce bounce bounce
go up hold it
and down okay now we will do
one last exercise extra
for balance because that's really
important for
pivots yeah so you can keep your hands
in your hips if you want now put
your weight on one foot only so i will
be your mirror
so just put it on this side yeah just
mirror me
that's fine and then put the free leg in
front of you like this yeah without
touching the floor
on the air and let's keep this position
for
five seconds let's count to five one
two three four
five yeah now let's move the leg to the
side without touching the floor
keep the foot straight yeah let's count
to five one
two three four
five now let's move the free leg to the
back
without touching the floor and let's
count to five one
two three
four five okay now let's change the leg
put your weight on this side now and put
the free leg in front of you
let's count to five one
two three
four five now let's move the leg to the
side
make sure that the hip is straight yeah
let's count to five
one two don't touch the floor
three four five
now move the free leg to the back make
sure that the hip is straight
yeah and let's count to five one
two three four
five okay now we're finished good
so let's go to the first preparation
exercise
okay the preparation exercise for pivots
is very simple
it's about balance and dissociation
and it works like this i will show you
from the front
because it's the easiest and you can
just mirror me
yeah just go to the same side so you put
your weight
on one leg yeah on this side yeah
the free foot you put it behind yeah
legs are touching
each other and the foot is together with
the standing foot
and of course a little bit lifted from
the floor
yeah and then make sure that your core
is
tight yeah straight and you make a small
circle with the arms
like this yeah if you want you can bend
your standing knee
a little bit um this will give you a bit
more stability
and then the idea is you start looking
at the center and then you turn
90 degrees more or less than degrees
towards the side of your standing leg
yeah then you return to the center
and then you look towards the side of
your free leg
yeah and then you return to the center
this is one repetition
and we do it eight times so it's one
and one and two and
two and three and three eight times and
then we change the leg
and we do the same on the other leg yeah
now when you do it at home or alone you
can use
music do it with the rhythm of the music
or you do it on your own
i'm going to use the i will use the
metronome because it's a very clear
reference
and the way i set my metronome is always
the same
it's 58 bpm that's the tempo that's how
fast it goes
and it's two beats per bar yeah
first speed secondly
and the way we will use the rhythm with
the exercise
is like this we will spend two bits
looking
in each direction so if you start on
this leg
yeah then it's going to be bit
bit bit bit
bit bit big b
so two bits on each direction yeah
one two one two
okay and that's one with it eight times
with each leg okay so i'll leave the
method
here
and let's start let's do it together so
uh let's start with this leg yeah it
doesn't matter which one you use first
yeah so put your weight on this side
yeah
bend the knee a little bit put the free
foot behind
a little lift it in the air make sure
your core
is tight and straight yeah make a
circle with your arms and then first we
turn towards the standing leg
then center and then we turn towards the
free leg
okay let's do it together eight times
one one
two two
three three
four four
five five
six six
seven seven
and eight eight
eight eight
okay now relax less
and let's change the weight let's put it
on this side now
yeah so wait here make sure that your
foot is completely flat on the floor
that the toes are open yeah you can
wiggle them a little bit
yeah relax and open put the foot behind
together with a free with a standing leg
bend the knee a bit core straight
arms in a circle low below the chest
yeah let's do it three times
one one
two two
three three
four four
five five
six six
seven seven
eight eight
okay good so
um one tip for this
exercise is that um
try the whole time to think
about your standing foot yeah when you
are
looking in different directions yeah
left
right center usually we get distracted
with the directions yeah when we look
somewhere we have the tendency to go
there so even if you are looking
to the side yeah don't get distracted
with
what you are seeing on your side or the
fact that you are looking there
yeah keep thinking about your standing
foot
all the time yeah then return
and no matter where you think of your
standing
foot yeah don't lose contact with your
standing foot think about it all the
time
and this will help you with your balance
okay
so let's go to the first pivot exercise
okay the first exercise for pivots is
going to be
the general purpose one because we will
do 90 degrees pivots
with the free foot in zero position okay
so i will show you from behind yeah
the zero position is not exactly with
feet parallel
but it's with the free foot behind the
standing foot
like this in a v yeah so
basically you are touching the
middle of the free foot yeah this part
between the heel and the ball the middle
the soft part is touching the heel
of the standing foot yeah so like this
that's the zero position that we use
yeah
okay so first we will turn 90 degrees
towards the standing leg yeah
towards the direction of the standing
leg and then we change the leg
and we will do the same with the other
leg we will pivot
towards the standing leg then we will
change to the first leg
and we will pivot in the other direction
so we will give it away
from the standing leg towards the free
leg
yeah and then we will change the leg and
we will do the same
we will pivot towards the free leg yeah
and each exercise we will do it
16 times yeah so twice eight
okay and we will do it
with the metronome of course
and the way we will use the rhythm
yeah 58 gpm and two beats per bar
is that each pivot will take two beats
one two yeah the first bit
will be for the torso and the second
beat will be for the heel
like this torso
hip torso hip
torso hip okay and
this is important because during the
exercise
you should really work on your
dissociation it's very important yeah
don't turn your hip until the torso is
completely turned into the
target direction yeah so you do
torso and hip yeah and you should
actually try to turn the hip as late as
you can
yeah first turn the torso completely
completely
and then here yeah if you do it like
this
instead of turning the hip too early
so that the body turns like a block
all together it will be easier yeah
if you disassociate it will be easier to
keep your balance
during the exercise yeah okay
so uh
metronome and i will put it here
and i will start always with my back to
you so that you can copy
uh on which leg of my weight and towards
what direction we are pivoting
okay so let's start with the first one
put
your weight on the left leg the right
foot
is behind yeah bend a bit the knee make
sure your core is straight
and make a small circle with the arms in
front of you
yeah and we turn towards the standing
leg that means
to the left 90 degrees
16 times okay let's do it together
one two
three four
five six
seven eight eight more
one two
three four
five six
seven eight
okay relax the leg if you need
and now we put the weight on the right
leg
left foot behind and we turn towards the
standing leg
that means to the right yeah 16 times
let's do it together
and one
two three
four five
six seven
eight eight more one
two three
four five
six seven
eight okay good
now we do the other version so we put
our weight
on the left right foot behind and now we
turn
away from the standing leg so towards
the free leg that means
now to the right okay
let's do it 16 times together
one two
three four
5 6
7 8
8 more 1 2
3 four
five six
seven eight
okay now change the leg
put the weight on the right put the left
foot behind
and now let's turn towards the free leg
so
to the left okay 16 times let's do it
together
one two
three four
five six
seven eight
one two
three four
five six
seven eight
okay good that's very good
now of course you could now do this
exercise doing
180 degree spirits but i wouldn't do
that
until your 90 degree spirits are
perfect yeah that your balance is always
good
that you don't need the free food yeah
we always need it
sometimes a little bit yeah that you
don't need it at all
yeah so i would keep practicing with
90 degrees pivot for a while yeah
and then when all these things are
working well
yeah the as well that is really good
then you can try humidity okay
so let's go to the next exercise okay
for this exercise we will do the pivots
with our free leg behind like this
yeah behind with the toes pointing down
yeah and we do the pivots like this
now for the free foot be careful with
this look
when you have the free foot behind the
toes are pointing down
make sure that the heel doesn't fall to
the outside this is very common
if you forget a little bit about the
free leg and it's too
loose yeah too relaxed then
this happens so try to do this exercise
a little bit yeah move the heel to the
outside
and to the inside to the outside and to
the inside yeah
the correct position is like this to the
inside
yeah with the big toe touching the floor
like this yeah so when you do the pivots
you need to have a little bit of tension
on the leg
and on the ankle so that the leg is
always behind you
and always in this position yeah the
foot in this position
okay so like before we will do it
four times uh two times
with each leg turning towards the
standing leg
and two times with each leg turning
towards the free leg
so um what is this exercise good for
well for example when you are doing your
choose front for the man
and for the woman and you want to keep
the leg behind because it looks really
good
yeah like this and then you do just uh
forward with the leg behind
this is what this exercise is good for
yeah and when you are turning
away from the standing leg towards the
free leg
yeah that's good for example for the man
when he wants to do a pivot
and wants to catch the foot of the woman
or
do something like this then that's
exactly the movement that you are using
so
this exercise is good for that okay
so um as before
we will do it with the metronome and we
will pay
special attention to the dissociation
yeah so remember we use one beat
for the torso and one bit for the hip
yeah it looks like this now and torso
hip torso and the idea is that you don't
turn the hip until the torso is
completely
turned 90 degrees yeah
you should always have the feeling like
the hip is a little bit lazy
it comes very very late okay
so let's do it together 16 times to each
side
okay so now we put our weight
on the left leg and the
right foot is behind like this yeah you
can bend the
standing knee a little bit if you want
that helps
stability make sure the hip is straight
your
core is tight make a small circle with
the arms
and now we are going to turn 16 times
towards the left towards the standing
leg
okay so let's do it 16 times together
on one
two three
four five
six seven
eight eight more one
two three
[Music]
four five
six seven
eight okay relax the legs
and change weight now put the weight on
the right
left foot behind toes toe
big toe on the floor heel towards the
inside
circle with the arms 16 times now
turning towards the standing exhale
towards the right
okay let's do it together
and one
two three
[Music]
four five
six seven
eight eight more one
two three
four five
six seven
eight okay now
relax the legs put the weight again on
the left
right foot behind and now we turn
away from the standing leg so towards
the free leg so now
we turn to the right okay 16 times let's
do it together
one two
[Music]
three four
five six
seven eight eight more
one two
three four
five six
seven eight
okay good now change the weight
put it now on the right leg
left foot behind and we turn towards the
free leg so we turn to the left now
16 times let's do it together
and one
two three
four five
six seven
eight eight more one
two three
four five
six seven
eight i okay
great
very good so let's go to the next
exercise
okay in this exercise we will do our
pivots
with the free leg on the side like this
yeah so now we will bend our standing
knee a little bit more
than before so that we can open the free
leg
a bit more yeah the foot is
stretched and the toe is on the floor
yeah so the exercise will look like this
first you turn the torso like before
with dissociation and then you do the
yeah torso build torso
torso pivot you see and the free leg the
free foot
is always tracing a 90 degrees arc
together with the pivot yeah it's like a
compass
an open compass now a technical tip that
is important
after you have turned the torso and then
you do the pivot
it's important that the hip the
standing leg and the free leg move
together
as a block yeah like this
one yeah that you don't for example
start moving the free leg before you do
the pivot like this
leg and pivot or the opposite then you
put the p
button in the leg yeah uh don't have the
free leg
loose yeah it needs to have tension
yeah and it needs to move together with
the hip
all together yeah and this kind of
exercise
is very useful for of course for planios
yeah this is how a planet
could look like yeah or for the woman in
a calicita
if she decides to open the freeway yeah
it's also very useful
so like before we will do it four times
twice on each leg turning towards the
standing leg and then twice with each
leg turning
towards the free leg and we will use
again the metronome
and we will use the same rhythm as
before yeah
so two bits per pivot the first bit is
for the torso
yeah and the second beat is for the hip
so that you make sure that you are
dissociating yeah
so it's um
torso hip torso
hip torso hip okay
good so let's do it together
16 times on each direction
so put your weight on the left
the right leg is open to the side bend
the knee
yeah put the big toe on the floor
stretch the foot make a circle with your
arms
and let's do it 16 times turning towards
the standing leg so turning
towards the left okay let's go
one two
three four five
six seven
eight eight more one
two three
four five
six seven
eight okay relax the legs
and now put your weight on the right leg
left leg open to the side bend the knee
circle with your arms and we do it 16
times turning towards the standing leg
so
towards the right let's do it together
one two
three four
five six
seven eight
one two
three four
five six
seven eight
okay now relax the legs
and we put the weight again on the left
right leg open to the side and now
we turn towards the free leg so we turn
towards the right 16 times let's do it
together
and one
two three
four five
six seven
eight anymore one
two three
four five
six seven
eight okay relax
and we put the weight on the left on the
right now
left leg open to the side and we turn
this stance to the left because we will
turn towards the free leg
okay 16 times together
and one
two three
four five
six seven
eight eight more one
two three
four five
six seven
eight okay
great so um
if you want to try 180 degrees uh
this exercise this one is quite good
because
this pivot is very safe yeah why
because you're bending the knee a lot
that means you have a lot of stability
and this foot is on the floor and quite
away from you
yeah so you have a second contact
with the floor which gives you a little
bit of support and this contact is not
close to you
it's far away so that makes your base
really wide and safe so here you could
try
180 degrees if you want
yeah and once you feel secure with this
you can
try 180 degrees with the other exercises
okay that's a suggestion good let's go
to the next exercise okay in this
exercise we will do
our pivot with the free leg crossed
in front like this yeah
uh the weight is always on the back foot
yeah you don't put weight on the front
foot the front foot
is free yeah but it's crossed in front
yeah and the exercise looks like this
first you turn the torso
and then you turn the hip
torso heat towards your hip yeah
peel like this yeah so
um when do you use this well for example
for the woman
this is a position that she could use
for example during
a calicita yeah the man is turning
around her she's turning
and she can do lots of adornments yeah
and she can also do
this sometimes yeah for example
before a change of weight in which she
can use the other leg
yeah things like this and for the man
well this is a very
effective beautiful and common position
for example when he is in a hero
with the woman doing a malinetta around
him
and then he goes front and then he when
he pivots
he does a lapid that ends with the foot
crossed in front
yeah so something like this whoa
warm yeah and then pivot right
and then front pole something like that
yeah so it's something that the man can
use very effectively
inside the heel okay so a few technical
tips
yeah make sure that when you are doing
the pivot because you are busy with the
pivot it can happen
that during the period the free leg
that is in front relaxes too much
because you are concentrating on the
pivot
and then the knee falls to the side and
then your legs look like a four
like this no make sure that you keep a
little bit of tension
on the free leg so that the knee is
always looking forward
yeah always looking forward yeah for
example if i am
here and then i turn the torso at the
end of the pivot
the knee has to look forward and the
legs need to look tight
the point of this pivot with the leg in
front with the free leg in front
is that from the outside it has to look
like
you don't have two legs you just have
one big leg
yeah so although the front foot doesn't
have any weight
it's very close to the floor almost
touching
so that it looks like you are pivoting
on both
feet of course you are not you are
pivoting on the back foot
but it looks like
feet halfway yeah it's very flat on the
floor
that's the illusion okay so keep that in
mind
and we will do it with the metronome
again pay attention to your dissociation
so make sure that you make the pivot as
late as possible
after you turn the torso so one bit is
for the torso and one feet is for the
hip
like this
so we will do it four times like before
twice with each leg turning towards the
standing leg
and twice with each leg turning towards
the free leg
okay so let's do it
so get ready put your weight on the
left and the right foot in front
very close with a standing leg you can
bend the knees
to have more stability make sure your
core is engaged
and straight make a small circle with
the arms and let's do it 16 times
turning towards the standing leg
so to the left okay let's do it together
and one
two three
four five
six seven
eight eight more one
two three
four five
six seven
eight okay now relax the legs
and put your weight on the right leg
yeah
cross the left leg in front
the left foot flat almost touching the
floor but without weight
okay knees together one in front of the
other
and core engaged circle with the arms
and now we turn towards the right okay
towards the
standing leg let's go
one two
three four
five six
seven eight
one two three
four five
six seven
eight okay relax the legs
now um put the weight again on the left
cross the right leg in front of the left
and now we will turn 16 times towards
the free leg
so we turn towards the right okay
let's do it together
one two
three four
five six
seven eight
eight more one two
three four
five six
seven eight
okay now put the weight
on the right leg and then cross the left
foot
in front of the right one one knee in
front of the other
bend the knees hips straight and circle
the arms and now we turn 16 times
towards the three legs so towards
the left okay let's do it together
um one two
three four
five six
seven eight
one two
three four
five six
seven eight
okay great so we use
the four possibilities okay great so
let's go to the last uh pivot exercise
okay for this last exercise we will do
the pivot
with the three leg cross behind
like this yeah one knee is behind the
other knee
so don't have both knees visible from
the front
that's wrong one it has to be behind the
knee so your legs make
like an x yeah and the center of the
eggs
are the knees yeah and the back foot now
is the free one of course
and the foot look i show you from the
behind
be careful that the food is not like
this
that the toes are looking to the outside
that means that the leg is not crossed
enough so you have to cross it fully
so that your toes look to the inside
yeah and this is actually
good because it it's not only that it
looks better
yeah it's also that allows you to
push one foot against the other yeah the
toes are pushing
against the side of the standing foot
and this pressure of the feet together
with the pressure
here with one leg pressing against the
other
helps you to do the pivot yeah to keep
the balance
during the period so this is the
exercise yeah
people with the free leg cross behind
so what is this exercise good for
well for example for the woman
this is a position that she can have
also during academia
let's say that calicitas for the woman
give her a lot of possibilities
basically every position
of the free leg is a potential candidate
for the woman to use
in accolade yeah and for the man
obviously
this is great for androskis yeah
for for example uh this kind of figure
where you do what happens yeah so this
exercise
targets enrolls composition yeah it will
help you with that
okay so um like before
we will do it four times twice with each
leg
first turning towards the standing leg
and then
turning towards the free leg
okay and like before we'll do it with
the metronome
one bit is for the torso and one bit is
for the hips
so that you make sure that you are
dissociating
right yeah so torso
hip torso heat yeah
and i really recommend you that you turn
your hip
as late as you can yeah make sure that
the torso is completely
turned before you do the period
yeah torso hip yeah
don't be afraid to be late yeah just
give time to the torso and bring the leg
the hip later yeah this will make it
look much
nicer from the outside and it will feel
better in your body
okay so let's do it with the
metronome
so get ready we will start with the
weight
on the left leg so we cross
the right leg behind yeah
here because of the position of the legs
you can't
bend the knees so much yeah it's not so
comfortable so
you need to keep your legs fairly
straight they don't need to be
completely straight because this is also
uncomfortable
so a little bit bent but very little
just relax okay now we will turn
16 times towards the left because we are
turning towards the
standing leg okay so let's do it
together
ah one
two three
four five
six seven
eight eight more one
two three
four five
six seven
eight okay relax the legs
and i'll put the weight on the right
cross the left behind
make sure that your hip is straight and
your core is engaged
yeah make a small circle with the arms
below the chest
and let's turn 16 times to the right
towards the standing leg okay let's do
it together and
one two
three four
five six
seven eight
anymore one two
three four
five six
seven eight
okay now relax the legs
put the weight on the left again the
right leg is crossed behind
and now we will turn towards the free
leg
so in this case we turn to the right now
16 times
yeah get ready and let's do it together
one two
three four
five six
seven
eight more one two
three four
five six
seven eight
okay good change weight now put the
weight on the right
cross the left leg behind yeah make sure
that the knees
are aligned yeah one knee behind
the other knee get ready and we turn 16
times now
to the left towards the free
leg okay let's go
1 2
3 4
5 6
7 eight
eight more one
two three
four five
six seven
eight okay
great so
ah that's it we did all the exercises
yeah congratulations now one
last tip
every dancer has a trick to
help balance and precision with this
kind of exercises yeah for example
i advise that no matter what you are
doing no matter what people you are
doing that you concentrate on your
standing
foot yeah uh for example when you are
turning preparing for the pivot yeah
think of your standing foot yeah
feel the contact of the standing foot
with the with the floor
yeah and some people find it
useful to concentrate specifically
on the heel of the foot yeah
so for example when you are doing a
pivot
you are imagining that you are placing
the
heel behind you yeah the heel behind you
yeah oh yeah sometimes this can be
useful
why because the heel during a pivot the
heel is the free part of the food you
have to lift
the heel a little bit in order to be
able to pivot
yeah if the heel is on the floor you
can't do it
so because the heel is above the floor
lifted a little bit
it's free and it's uh
you could imagine that that's exactly
the part that is directing
the pivot so you think about your heel
yeah put it behind you behind
you and that can help you
have more position with the pivot and
better balance
another tip that some dancers use
is especially if you are in a position
where your feet are together for example
zero position
or crossed in front or close behind
yeah these positions where the feet are
very close to each other
some dancers imagine that this the
heel from the standing foot yeah
is pushing the free foot yeah
that's another trick you can use to help
you with the pivot
yeah so my free food is together with
the standing foot
and my heel on the standing foot
is pushing the free
foot on each pivot 90 degrees
it also works on this position yeah
in this case the heel is pulling
the free foot
90 degrees or if you are like this
the heel is pushing
the free foot 90 degrees yeah so but
in any case many people think about the
heel
during pivots the heel of the standing
foot this is a little trick that
maybe can help you it's just about
visualization
okay so thank you very much thank you
a lot to the people who are supporting
the channel with donations
i really appreciate that a lot yeah
thank you very much
keep practicing i hope you improve and i
will see you in the next video